Mr.
President, I'm interested
in the timeline today on the anniversary.
You spoke to your own forces
and you called for victory
within this year.
You have heard the Western friends,
your partners talk about
as long as it takes.
You know that
the Russian leader believes
that time is on his side
Why do you think that it's possible
by the end of the year?
And how do you assess
the meaning of as long as it takes
from your Ukrainian perspective?
Thank you for the question.
Indeed, I would want it very much
if each of us, each partner
and us in our country,
if we stay, is one strong fist
and if our partners are united
for our victory,
because this is a victory of values.
If they stick to all their words
to all their terms
and it's not just blah, blah, blah,
I believe in it.
We have been strong partners
and there is evidence for that.
If we do our important homework,
if we all complete our tasks,
victory will be inevitable.
I am certain there will be victory.
I don't think I know it will happen
this year.
We have everything for it.
Motivation belief, friends, diplomacy,
and you.
We have united all powers
against this invasion,
and I think not
a single country in the world
can stand up independently.
Against such an aggressive war.
Maybe the United States could,
but fortunately,
they do not share a border
with the Russian Federation.
Nevertheless,
it is several countries in the world
Ukraine is not alone.
We are help
our friends for our shared values
so that this war doesn't spread,
so that this aggression doesn't spread.
We know exactly what Putin wants,
what the Kremlin wants,
and the military
and political leadership
of the Russian Federation.
So it is important for all of us
to be focused.
And for each of us to do our work
and then we shall have victory.
Because truth is on our side.
And it is a great shame
when we lose children
whom we love on the front line
while they are abandoning everyone
and not counting their dead
That is their choice
upon the president.
Good evening.
Mr.
President, I would like to thank you
for your example of Invincible
in your face.
We all believe in victory.
Many international experts
say that it is a war of attrition,
and that's
neither side has enough resources
to gain an obvious victory
on the battlefield
and that negotiations are inevitable.
How do you imagine these negotiations
and what will be the final victory
for you?
I don't think in theoretical terms
how these negotiations will take place
and what they are.
We take specific steps.
Ukraine has initiated a peace formula
at the G20, even though Jim G.
We would and the
whole world would like to see it as G.
19.
We presented the peace formula
a step by step plan,
and we can see the results of what Russia
has done here
and how it affects not only our security,
because there have been many crises
that have been caused by the aggression
of the Russian Federation,
you know, the nuclear station in America
that and separatists has occupied
the food security
and all the chains, the Black Sea and,
you know, all the points on the plan
and we have proposed steps to go today.
We can see interest
in the implementation
of this peace formula
and we can see support
and I want to thank countries
which
141 countries at the U.N.
Assembly
supported our peace initiatives
last night.
The next step, as I see it,
as much as possible, as they say,
I would like as many as possible states
involved in a founding summit
so that it is effective, productive,
and to
make sure that it actually happens.
Will it goodwill this will occur
with a large number of countries
involved.
I am working
with my team and with partners
ship sets to to make sure
that not only our strategic partners
supporting us are represented because the
from the very first days and seconds
of this war,
we have been working
to involve
representatives of various continents.
We want Latin America involved.
And I would want this.
And we are taking steps to involve
the great African continent
in the peaceful Mela at this summit.
We are also working, to be honest.
I want India involved.
I want China involved.
And it's true our task is to involve
absolutely everybody.
And to show
here is respect
for territorial integrity,
for the UN charter,
for the rights to live
And as the more countries
we involve from various continents,
the more powerful our support will be.
And our peace formula.
You know, I think it's quite democratic.
We did it in a democratic way.
The approach is simple to reduce risks
and the risk of you are countries
supporting us.
We would like some countries to support
nuclear security
one point on the plan
or environmental security.
A lot is mines, as you know,
and we can see it
and we can see the results
And so there are many points on the plan,
and we have proposed it.
And and
there is the end to the war
It is an important point
because we need security guarantees
and this is necessary.
It should be a package,
a security package
for Ukraine, for Ukraine,
And we can see that this is a war
that has a huge effect.
And so we need
security guarantees for Europe.
That's what I understand.
So as soon as the res implementation
and therefore respect
for international law
and for people of Ukraine,
and if it is implemented we will come
to the diplomatic
end of this war.
And but until then,
we need to make sure that there is
respect
would let let's go to Mexico and get the
Mexican TV.
Wait for you, Mike. Please.
Wait for you, Mike.
Such a great Olympic reform.
We as
you recalled the U.N.
resolution over what, over
140 countries
voted for the withdrawal
of Russians from Ukraine.
What would you say to the minority
of countries
which did not support this resolution,
even though you wanted or abstained
was that not permanent?
Should I give you in order to understand
what war is,
what the effects of war is
and the losses?
Because you don't only lose territory,
you lose people living people.
And if you've not been at war
and you haven't forwards
or you haven't lost,
you don't know the pain
to the pain it causes for each person.
Mr..
It is difficult
to get this information through.
And that's why
we work with you every day.
So that this understanding
doesn't come from
direct contact with the war.
It's it's a weak position.
To be distance,
to be at a distance
and to say, well, we're not sure.
But how can you be sure?
Does it need to take war and loss law
and torture,
a war and torture, war and rape?
For people
to become aware
of the consequences of this bloody war
It's very clever,
but it's sick.
The leadership of the Russian Federation.
And that's why we need diplomacy
and we need journalism
to bring this to get this through.
And it's difficult for us
that there are a number of countries
opposed to this.
And but look, 141 are in favor.
They do respect territorial integrity
and sovereign sea.
And this is the response.
How these countries know
what their attitude is to the aggressor.
Yes.
The aggressor must leave
a sovereign territory.
How shall we work with the others?
We are working. I believe Ukraine
needs to make steps
forwards to come towards
the countries of the African continent.
We have worked a long time
for a long time.
We have not paid enough
attention to them.
And I think that's a big mistake.
And that's why we have a large program
to extend
the ambassadorial presence in the region
and also look at our grain from Ukraine
and other initiatives
about food security.
So we need to make daily investments
into peace.
And I think we have wasted
time for a long time
since our independence.
We've wasted time,
and that's
why we're now fighting for independence.
So this is no accident.
There was no strong fist
of Ukrainian partners
I'm glad it's is there now,
but it isn't complete.
There are some missing
from this strong united fist.
And I will tell you
who is missing the African continent,
Latin America.
They are very important.
And I would like to hold a conference.
I'd like to hold a summit of Latin
American countries with Ukraine.
And it is difficult
for me to leave the country.
But for this meeting, I would
I will want to get it
through to them,
to their media, to their society.
They know the crown will not fall
from my head.
I am ready
our diplomats are ready to work.
24, seven.
Where else can we get extra hours?
We will do it.
And that's how
we should have worked
for the last 30 years.
Unfortunately, it is unfortunate
that the war
is had to take the world
for us to start this process.